Uh, next question today, can DEMEC Democrats
retake the Senate in 2020?
This is a good topic to discuss.
We, we've only talked about this a little
bit, but now that it's getting closer, I want
to address it again.
And most of the discussion about 2020 is about
the White House and there's the presumption
that Democrats can keep, if not extend control
of the House of Representatives.
But the Senate is a really interesting body,
uh, to look at.
And unfortunately the answer is that Democrats
almost definitely cannot take the Senate in
2020 now it's mathematically possible.
It's mathematically possible for Democrats
to take the Senate in 2020 Republicans control
it right now, 53 to 47 so democrats need plus
three and the White House because the vice
president becomes the tie breaking vote.
Or if Donald Trump is reelected, democrats
need plus four in order to take control of
the Senate.
Now if you look just at the numbers, Hey,
33 seats plus the special election for John
McCain seat are up.
Democrats are only down three and there's
34 total seats that are available.
The problem is for Democrats that have those
seats that are up in 2020 Republicans are
defending 22 of them.
Meaning that if Democrats hold all of their
seats, there are actually only 22, not 34
seats that they could take from Republicans.
Most of those 22 are safe Republican seats.
So when you get right down to it, the opportunity
for Democrats is basically Colorado Republican,
Cory Gardner is vulnerable in Colorado.
Susan Collins in Maine.
That's a possibility that would be to, uh,
beyond that, it gets really tough.
I mean, okay.
You can talk about Joni Ernst in Iowa.
You could talk about Tom, tell us in North
Carolina, you could talk about the Arizona
question mark for John Mccain's old seat.
Uh, there are people talking about, hey, what
about getting rid of Mitch Mcconnell and Kentucky?
I think that's an extreme long shot and I
hope I'm not misremembering.
Mcconnell is up in 2020.
I believe.
If he's not, then it's a total nonstarter.
I'm having a, a brain glitch right now.
Uh, and then aside from that for, but there,
there's the chance that Democrats lose that
Alabama seat, that Doug Jones one in a special
election, he has to defend that seat and he
barely defeated a cereal accused child sex
assault or so, uh, now he has to try to win
reelection.
They're in a very, very red state and it is
not looking particularly likely to me.
Um, so Ken Democrats Take Care, uh, a take
control there.
I think it's extraordinarily unlikely.
So for me, the longterm plan is take the White
House in 2020, keep or extend the lead in
the House of Representatives and then look
for 20, 22 at taking over the Senate.
I haven't even looked at which seats are up
there.
Um, and often the party that takes control
of the White House doesn't do so well in that
president's first midterm, but those are problems
we can deal with when we get to them in the
immediate win.
Every race we can, taking control of the Senate,
not looking through
for likely for Democrats in plant.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Uh, become a member, become a patron.
I'll speak to you then the